in this video i'm going to show you how
to take an active business and make it
into passive income
so the goal that most of us
entrepreneurs have right
is to is to is to have freedom right so
we want to not work
or not have to work and have money
coming towards us and the thing is is
what i have learned
is that you can make anything passive
and you can make anything
active and one of the difficulties for
entrepreneurs when you switch from
entrepreneur to investor is that you
want to take your passive things and
make them more active in order to
increase your returns
and that's a very tempting thing to do
because we're entrepreneurial and we can
see
where the margin is getting lost right
but if you always chase
time then you'll always uh be able to
make whatever it is like if you chase
time always
then eventually you'll end up with all
your time and you should have some left
over that is coming towards you
right and so i'll give you a quick
example gym launch uh
two years ago i think mates it made 17
million i mean according to our quality
of earnings we made 17 million in profit
in uh 2019 2018 2018 excuse me 2018. and
this year
we'll probably do 8 million ish
in profit so you're like whoa you cut in
half here's the difference
when we did 17 million i was the
business it was 100
alex's face wrapped with a monetization
structure wrapped around it i was taking
calls i was doing all of these things i
was definitely ceo i was definitely in
front of the marketing i was also the
product i was doing all those things
right
right now the business basically
generates half the profit but it
involves me for about 90 minutes a week
and so my my dollars per hour are
significantly higher because now i also
have
all these other things that i can do uh
with the time that has earned back
for me and so what i want to walk
through in this video is
kind of the the process and how to do it
and when to do it and so one of the
issues that i see
people starting out and when i say
starting out you know making a million
three million etc is that i'll get
messages from them
and they're like dude i think i'm ready
to outsource my business and i'm like
but why like i don't think you've gotten
to the i mean maybe maybe somebody who's
at
a zillion you know says to me like why
are you doing that now but i think for
me i would my answer would be like i've
achieved the wealth that i
that i want i don't need to to guess it
anymore and now it's really
using a different metric for success
which is like how how much can i spend
you know how much time can i spend with
my life my wife how much time can i
spend um
whenever i want in the gym uh working
out uh eating the stuff i want to eat et
cetera right how can i have other
metrics for success
spending time you know meeting people
etc and doing stuff like this which i
never did while i was growing the
business
not in this way right and so anyways
the the thing that i see people do is
they try and jump out of the ceo seat
too
soon but what i want to do is give you
the best model for how to do it when
it's right
right because ultimately if you can turn
your active income into passive income
i just love this quote you get paid on
what you do you get returns on what you
own
right gym launch as an enterprise is far
more valuable or my fitness companies
because there's a couple there
are far more valuable now than they were
when it made 17 million dollars in
profit because
then no one would ever buy it right
because no one's going to buy
me right it's just a producer
personality brand whereas now it is an
enterprise that generates revenue by
providing value to customers on a
consistent basis and i have nothing to
do with it and as a management team at
place etc
right and so as we make these
transitions right
going from ceo to owner you have to go
from active to passive
so this is the mental framework that uh
that it took me a really long
time to discover when figuring this out
all right so think about your
trajectory as an entrepreneur right so
first you start you do everything
right and then all of a sudden you start
delegating out the things that are the
lowest value
time wise right if you can pay someone
10 an hour or 15
an hour to do you know 10 10 hours a
week of your work then you get 10 hours
back
and then you can put higher value skills
in those 10 hours and then make more
money and then fundamentally that's
literally what entrepreneurship is just
arbitraging time over and over and over
again
and then leveling up your own skill sets
so that with the time that you get back
you can provide you can do more valuable
things and that's i think one of the
bigger issues that i see a lot too is
that
people will outsource their time and
then not fill their time back up with
higher value skills right
now if that's what you want to do for
lifestyles that's cool but like in terms
of the game
um if you if you seek to grow then you
need to re re
put more things in your stack and take
the extra 10 hours and do something even
more valuable maybe it's marketing again
or learning a new channel or improving
the product or whatever it is that's
more valuable than maybe frontline
support
right or whatever and so the idea here
is going from active to passive
and so as i was saying when you replace
that role
right what you did is you got time back
right
and so if you do that enough times um
you're always
you know doing the next thing but here's
what's kind of funny and this is the
mental framework that i want to give to
you
imagine like let's say you look back at
what you were doing a year ago and it
probably should look different than what
you're doing today right hopefully if
you're
if you're growing in your business what
you're doing then versus what you're
doing now is different
and so if you look back to what you were
doing then and you see the progress that
you made to what you're doing now
then rather than saying okay well in 12
months i'm going to be doing all these
things and all these things are gone
if you can actually jump two steps
forward then your business could be 100
growing at the same pace it is now
with somebody doing both of these things
that you were doing and then you just
owning it
all right and i know you're like wait
what does he mean i'll try and explain
this again
so this is like if you can understand
this concept
it will set you free and allow you to
turn your active income businesses into
passive income uh things that you get
returns on these become assets that
become sellable one of the number one
issues that
people have is like you can't sell
personality brands you can't sell their
own businesses because they're so
integrally involved in them
right and this is one of the mistakes a
lot of people make especially smaller
entrepreneurs is they're like
you know my business makes let's say
three million dollars a year right in in
net profit
well if if it would cost you know a
million and a half to get all of the
leadership and executives in order to do
all the stuff that you're doing which is
which is very realistic you might need
four or five high level leaders to do
that stuff
then your business is actually making a
million or a million and a half in
profit so it's actually half as valuable
so you're doing a million and a half
dollars a year of
payroll work because you're getting paid
for that and then your business is
returning you an
extra one and a half million so your
your total as a person are netting three
million dollars but the business is
generating 1.5
and you are generating 1.5 if you can
delineate that concept it will serve you
very well
in business and especially with the
concept i'm saying right now so the idea
is
what we want to do is take two steps
forward from where we're at right now
not one because if you take one step
forward you delegate what you're doing
now and then you start doing the next
thing
right that you need to do but if you
delegate what you're doing now and then
you get someone else to do the thing
that you should be doing next
then you can take a step back and now
you're owning the business while this
person now does the thing that you were
doing before
and that is ultimately how you can take
your active thing and turn it into
passive
and now you're an owner who looks at the
enterprise
and then what's crazy about this is that
you can actually see the weaknesses of
your own business far
better when you're outside of it looking
in and see
you can see the marketplace better you
can see what your customers are saying
better you just get so much more
perspective and then you really become
the chairman of the board
and then you're really meeting with the
ceo and you're you're talking to the ceo
about their direct reports how they can
improve as a leader
and what they need to do um in order to
kind of like and help them cast the
vision for the company
that's really it and the thing is the
vision doesn't change that frequently
and so you need to be smart about
why you're choosing to go in the
direction you are but once you've made
the decision there's not a lot of change
that has to happen
right it's really like how can we
execute consistently to get there
and so big picture to wrap this puppy up
if you want to go from business running
to business ownership one don't do it
too soon and this is the probably the
number one mistake that i see people
make is that they do it too soon
two if you are going to do it then if
you can think about what you get paid on
versus what your returns on
then you can separate what you do versus
what you own within the value that you
have in your own net worth like you are
valuable because you have skills
i i own that like i love this quote and
i'll say it again
poor people do the wrong things rich
people do
the right things wealthy people own the
right things
and so if you can think through that
within your own life it's like well i
need
right now you're probably doing the
right things and you own some of the
right things
right but you're doing both of these
things you're getting paid here you're
getting paid here and you're getting
returns here
so we want to put someone in place to do
the things that we're getting paid for
and then continue to keep the things
that we're getting returns on now mind
you
at some point that means that you might
lose half of your income if this if it's
50 50 right if
if your business makes you a million
dollars a year and then you make a
million dollars you're working your
business and the business nets you two
million
then you quitting right quitting and
hiring somebody else to do this thing
because you take two steps forward
if you do that then all of a sudden
you'll get a pay decrease
but your dollars per hour will go up
your enterprise value go up because now
it is something that is sellable that
operates without you
all right and so that actually means
that your net worth increases even
though
the the profit of the business decreases
and then here's what's cool
is that once you've done this right once
you've eliminated the step and now you
just own the thing that you get returns
on
now you can focus on how can i how can i
increase revenue here
trying to put more fingers on my on my
revenue right
how can i increase the revenue that i'm
making here
without me being involved because it's
all about the constraints that we can
put on ourselves so if i can
increase the revenue without me doing
anything how would i do that
and then you ask better questions and
then you get better answers and then
that is ultimately how you can grow the
wealth of the business without you
spending more time or making more
trade-offs that you don't want to make
because you've got in this game for
freedom
right and so anyways hope this is
valuable for you hit subscribe because
it was
check out the next video that comes up
because i'm sure it's sweet
and if you hated this uh then i would
ask that uh you can you can also tell me
that you hated it
and um i will send you love either way
so anyways keeping awesome let's look at
you next video
bye